[Music]
right
we've been dating for every year now and
I think it's about time people met my
beautiful girlfriend what about us
taking an adventure ease like Queens
Singapore Colleen's wedding my family
every time I bring them up the kitchen
maybe his parents up and he has to send
them money
pick up bags and get you checked in to
first day with this so your family is
rich
we're comfortable that is exactly what a
super rich person would say yeah they're
just the biggest developers in all a
Singaporean bachelors if people aren't
just rich
they're crazy rich you really should
have told me that you're like the
principal um of Asia
that's ridiculous much more of a hurry
mum this is Rachel shoot she just thinks
you're some like unrefined banana
there's a few fingers no on the outside
or white on the inside it was okay that
I chose to raise a family for me it was
a privilege but for you you may think
it's old-fashioned don't you want it to
be happy I know you're not what Nick
needs she's like trying to play games
chicken with me do you think I'm gonna
swerve like a chicken but you can't were
you gonna roll up and be like lockbox
[ __ ]
okay maybe like not as aggressive
I met a girl I fell in love and I want
to marry her your Nicholas young you're
untouchable but Rachel's not if you
prepped Rachel to face the walls I
really admire you takes guts coming all
the way over here facing expanding I
know this much you will never be enough
no it's about time someone stood up to
Aunt Eleanor well you not me Oh God
Chicago I was over here
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since I can remember my family has
been my whole life
Rachel Rachel if Nick chose me he would
those his family and if he chose his
family he might spend the rest of his
life for Zen ting you you dad you got an
ass you got nastier I love singing
dancing hiya folks
[Music]
[Applause]
hey handsome
looking for some rotten Cod I'm a woman
that's okay good time for you you were
the most decorated officers in this
department what do you see Jerry what
have a little respect for the dead nice
lunch we're gonna catch the bastards who
did these murders because bodies are
gonna start piling up I'm doing the best
damn cops I've ever seen
we don't know bag of [ __ ] yourself I I'm
not sure if I should say thank you
[Music]
oh god are you alright
diamond this your exes not doing this
do it
[Music]
oh sorry about your dead human friend
Phillip
[Music]
is Fallone he's servicing in class so
what I think it is please
tonight we're taking game night up a
notch oh boy someone in this room is
going to be taken and it's gonna be up
to you to find them it's a murder
mystery party whoever finds the victim
wins the grand prize you're not gonna
know what's real and what's fake wait a
sec you can't just come in here and
break the door ho feel guys make sure
you get a piece of this cheese it's just
okay Roger dad you drive safe I've
always enjoyed the camaraderie of good
friends competing in games of chance and
skill to revalue it seems like Ryan you
go first I'm scared
[Music]
it's not a joke people are in real
danger
oh so much worse
stop wait me I have kids at home now
with an ass like yet you don't oh thank
you oh no he died his instructions on
how to remove the bullets didn't have
rubbing alcohol so I got you this lovely
sharp good idea way to pivot and then a
squeaky toy for the pain Susan you take
Jerry to be your husband what's the
difference between Episcopalian and
Lutheran Episcopalians don't need fish
that's pescetarian us not a religion
they're all fanatics I don't know you
you may kiss the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years what for
the entire month of May every year we
play tag you never know when someone's
gonna pop up congratulations buddy
you're in doing great at it
everybody Gary's the best that ever
played and how it wants to retire never
been tagged just saying whose it touched
it
supernatural watches I don't know how to
do that I don't wear watch times a
construct some couples gone cruises some
couples go campaigning some couples go
to strip clubs and make a gangbang and
this is just what we love this is our
gang bang Wow seems like the game is
really flipped you guys connected
this game has given us a reason to be in
each other's lives think your dad would
have really wanted you to be yeah
[Music]
Yvonne
my balls but I scream what
he knows I'm lactose intolerant he's
taunting
[Music]